être handicapé c'est être prisonniers
des barrières de l' architecture depuis
des décennies exemple en 1972 que les
gens ont conscience de tous les
problèmes qui ont les handicapés les
trottoirs les marches les portes
autant d'obstacles sur la route des
fauteuils tous les handicapés ont besoin
de vivre qu'on tourne
il faut attendre 1975 pour une première
politique d'envergure sur le handicap
le premier ministre jacques chirac en
détailler les objectifs simplifier la
réglementation d'améliorer les
prestations consacré l'autonomie des
handicapés favoriser leur réinsertion
dans la société
la loi de 1975 rend obligatoire
l'accessibilité des locaux ouverts au
public
mais cinq ans plus tard force est de
constater qu'elle n'est pas appliquée
par ce retard c'est malheureusement la
conséquence d'un certain égoïsme je
pense et du fait qu'on a voulu trop
longtemps ignoré le problème le combat
des handicapés se joue aussi dans
l'opinion
des actions sont menées souvent par
l'association des paralysés de france en
1982 les manifestants s'étaient réunis à
paris pour réclamer une meilleure
accessibilité
en 2000 il était dans une cinquantaine
de villes devant des lieux choisis pour
leurs difficultés d'accès au net à
prendre l'accessibilité à tout le monde
pourquoi les gens apprennent un peu
conscience et que ça fasse évoluer un
peu
les mentalités et que nos chers amis
politiques s'en rende compte aussi un
petit peu nouvelles promesses en 2005 la
loi impose aux établissements recevant
du public de se mettre aux normes
d'accessibilité d'ici 2015
certaines villes ont pris le pas comme
nantes ville la plus accessible de
france en 2011 selon le baromètre de la
pf mais je combats d'année partout dans
pratiquement aller au cinéma au resto
partout et puis là j'aime bien parce que
le musée met à genoux pour me dire mais
les bons élèves ne sont pas courants
seuls 15 à 40% des établissements se
sont mises aux normes
effectivement excusez le petit
commerçant qui n'a pas conscience du
problème qui même si on le rencontre va
faire preuve de bonne volonté
autant les bâtiments publics la sécurité
sociale les médecins là j'ai un petit
peu plus de mal face à ce retard
l'échéance de 2015 a été repoussée entre
2018 et 2022 4 selon le type
d'établissement
en cas de non respect des normes
l'établissement risquera une amende de
45000 euros
[Musique]